[Music]  [Applause]  oh thank you  hope you find  it electrical problems in the building  aren't you always the same isn't it  are we back on the fifth floor yes the  thief my friend claire is here  i'm visiting her  she's expecting  what's me on  [Music]  [Music]  hello and welcome to staying awake i  have a sleeping disorder  i can't tell the difference  between my waking life  and dreams  [Music]  [Music]  stevie stephen  [Music]  i can't tell the difference  between my eyes and dreams  thank  lost the you lens  hope you find it  thanks  yeah oh my god you're alive what's wrong  with you mark  why did you call me mark  that must be very difficult  a voice in your head  [Music]  embrace the chaos  [Music]  is  [Music]  you